so we're talking about a perfect day so  sleep is really important what about  diet and stuff like that yeah I think uh  for a lot of people they try to keep it  light before the round actually like I  remember hearing the story from uh Peter  Fiddler some years back a Russian GM and  he said that kaspara would go and eat  like a big steak right before the game  and he would he would be completely fine  but I think for most players it's the  exact opposite you try to like eat like  some snacks like maybe some nuts a few  bars things of this nature or maybe just  like maybe fish something very light for  lunch  um before the game and then then you  probably eat a lot after the game that's  generally what you try to do but I don't  think there's any like specific diet  that makes a huge difference but every  everyone is different of course